hello and welcome to the introductory
lesson of the smack course offered by
simply learn smack abbreviated as social
mobile analytics and cloud is an
upcoming business model in many
organizations this lesson provides an
introduction to the course the next
screen displays the key features of
simply learn offerings before you start
please spend some time and go through
the key features of simply learned
offerings displayed on the screen let us
look at the objectives of this course in
the next screen by the end of this
course you will be able to describe SMAC
and its scope you will also be able to
explain SMAT components and their scope
respectively in the next screen we will
focus on the course overview as you may
be aware social mobile analytics and
cloud are individual technologies
however in recent years they have
emerged as an integrated whole called
smack stack this training course
provides information on social media
marketing and its impact on business the
mobile platform and its uses in various
industries big data and analytics in
businesses and cloud computing and its
benefits to organizations simply learns
smack course also lists various
certification and non certification
courses available in the social media
mobile analytics cloud computing fields
respectively we will look into the
target audience for this course in the
next screen the SMAC course is aimed at
professionals aspiring for a career in
any of the smack related fields the
primary target audience for this course
are consultants IT professionals sales
and marketing professionals technical
managers and project managers students
and other aspirants who wish to gain a
thorough understanding of SMAC can also
benefit from this course let us discuss
the prerequisites to take up courses
under each SMAC component in the
subsequent screen
simply learns smack course can be taken
up by any individual who wishes to gain
an understanding of smack however
components in the smack course have
separate prerequisites to complete them
the prerequisites for the courses in
each of the smack components that is
social media mobile analytics and cloud
are displayed in the table the
prerequisites to complete the social
media courses are basic knowledge of the
Internet ability to use popular search
engines and working knowledge of the MS
Office suite such as word spreadsheet
and PowerPoint
the prerequisites for mobile marketing
courses are similar to the social media
courses however a basic knowledge of
using mobile apps is required the
prerequisites for analytics courses
include fundamental knowledge of any
programming language
basic knowledge of Linux and fundamental
programming skills working knowledge of
Java may be required however it is not
mandatory to take up cloud computing
courses you must have 24 to 36 months of
work experience in IT networking network
storage system administration or data
center administration you also must be
familiar with any of the major
hypervisors for server virtualization
though vendor specific certifications in
virtualization are not required in the
next screen we will discuss how the SMAC
course could add value to professionals
SMAC professionals can use social media
in their job roles to reach larger
number of customers at a faster pace
they will be able to use the mobile
platform to bring efficiency in their
work
SMAC professionals can also use various
analytic tools that will help
organizations gain a stronghold on big
data
additionally SMAC professionals can use
cloud computing knowledge to reduce the
complexity of database management and
storage smack professionals with their
extensive knowledge of each component
can help organizations to reduce costs
and increase overall
efficiency in the next screen we will
focus on the list of lessons covered in
this course this course comprises five
lessons take a look at the lesson names
listed on the screen this concludes the
lesson on overview of smack the next
lesson provides an introduction to smack
wishing you all the luck for this course